[Music]
wave goodbye to the cold isolated island
of air angle and say hello to the warm
tones of the desert pub G's newest map
Miramar has everything the adventurous
spirit could ask for mountains to climb
cities to explore island getaways and 99
other deadly problems trying to kill you
[Music]
if you want to get the most fulfilling
experience out of your time in Miramar
here's some tips and important changes
you'll want to take note of let's start
with the vehicles the new bus is the
slowest and probably the worst vehicle
in pub G it has poor acceleration
laughable top speeds and it is trouble
climbing some of the most modest hills
if you like to go off-road this is not
the car for you however the bus isn't
entirely useless if you are rolling with
a full squad it provides enough space
and a good amount of protection better
yet if you hop out the minibus affords
you plenty of cover this is especially
useful in some of the more open spaces
of Miramar
[Music]
next we have the pickup there are two
variations scattered across Miramar
hardtop and open you should always go
for hardtop and squad because once again
it gives you more protection from
gunfire well it may not be as safer
reliable is the u-az from our angle it
is certainly the closest thing you'll
find to it in the desert now let's
compare shall we
[Music]
next up is the aqua rail and to be
honest you probably won't use it that
often it's quick and responsive but
because there are no rivers running
throughout the map you will rarely use
this vehicle
moving on to weapons miramar edged three
new guns the sawed-off shotgun the win
94 and the r45 the sawed-off shotgun is
my favorite of the bunch its range is
pretty bad but it can take the spot of a
sidearm it's a good option if you
typically don't hold on to shotguns late
in the game that being said I'd still
think of the sawed-off shotgun is a last
resort or an early game weapon next
let's have a look at the lever action
rifle the win 94 it packs a decent punch
but because it's incompatible with
almost every weapon attachment and its
reload speed as slow as hell it's
usually worth ignoring the third new
weapon is the r45 a 45 revolver that
comes equipped with a speed loader this
means you won't need to insert one
bullet at a time like the AR 1895 thank
God
the iron sights are pretty decent on
this thing as well making it somewhat
reliable at medium range these guns are
all nice additions but at the end of the
day you should be on the lookout for
assault rifles sniper rifle scopes and
silencers if anything they are even more
clutch on the open plains of Miramar so
now that we are familiar with the new
weapons and vehicles let's take a look
at the map itself and some of the new
mechanics if you've wandered around the
map at all you've probably noticed there
isn't nearly as much grass crawling into
the circle or hiding into the grass went
from a viable I'll be an annoying
strategy to a useless one thankfully
there are more large rocks scattered
throughout the map to hide behind and
finally the latest update adds bolting
not only does volting make life a lot
easier but more importantly it allows
you to vault through windows this means
you can easily escape from a building if
you're pinned down and you can surprise
enemies that are holed up in a house
and of course there are hot zones but
nothing as centrally located as the
iconic school typically larger buildings
have more loot and more covers so it's
good to start with those after I've
identified the flight path I typically
look for a settlement slightly off the
path that way you can get in a little
combat while getting some personal space
for looting despite these changes
positioning is still the most important
thing to consider listen carefully keep
to cover and knowing to engage the enemy
if you have any other tips feel free to
drop them in the comments below thank
you for watching